this week I've been practicing more my
design muscles
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
it's Monday 7pm I just got a five
brownie points and I'm missing six to my
500 grand challenge majority day of
today was from fide with my design
project that I've just started from
learning at and the challenges I took
part in helping people and get your own
i'm going running right now using the
rest of some from today
[Music]
still say and the second day I have been
working on the design of the new
projects the biggest problem that I face
is a lack of self confidence so I'm
learning right now how to how to sell
the the project I do the designs i do
and also how to believe in in you know
in yourself it's a bit hard especially
when you can not show the projects to
you know all of the world because they
are not your project and sometimes you
have to keep them for yourself and for
your clients on me believing this very
good at what you do pretty hard because
you know that they always can be better
I'm trying to build my self-confidence
the work that we are doing as designers
on the developers is just you know some
person of the final product and the rest
is selling and telling the story about
it and explain why we chose this way
that the other way so you have to rely
on what you're paying before you deliver
to the client and later you can iterate
over it ladies and gentlemen it's
Wednesday and I'm missing one brownie
point my 500 brownie challenge so it's
pretty exciting
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I I made it I got a 500 brownie
points there is three days I gathered
the missing points and I just completed
my challenge my challenge was to reach
500 brownie points before going to the
next level that in my case is data
visualization certification my dad
brownie point was gathered well in
JavaScript room so help JavaScript maybe
it's a sign to start being more present
than
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's Friday yesterday evening I set my
brackets to waken SAS brackets has nice
extensions and you can write answers and
later you'll get your satin CSS that's
great because the code editor makes
majority of stuff for me it's enough to
set the JSON file and remember about it
in each project you use sauce I have
less and less time right now for my copy
that's cooking so I prepared myself for
wag good coffee and the tweet dark
chocolate with fruit let's get back to
work I have to fill it right now they're
empty sites in the design that I'm
working on and I will also have to
connect the screens into prototype
majority of this week I stand an
experience design and just a little bit
of time in the code editor that's the
week most the devotees to design because
i'm working the new project i got
another graphic designer i learn at the
same time code so how to implement my
solutions and design so knowing at least
effect of us always helps somebody ask
in comments how i do the projects from
scratch i start with designs what i need
by starting with designs is stuck in
firstly with the users and the goal so
analyzing who is it for and how this
product that will be designed and
implemented in Pope how does it solve
their problems you have to put yourself
as it in users truth and think what
would I want to do right now where would
I like to go from this point to the
other one what would be the other point
when I'm what am I looking for in this
particular page these are journeys and
imagining like from which screen would I
go to which one it's really important
not to forget about something when I do
the designs for empower my projects very
often as i showed in some of the videos
i finish at something like that which is
a kind of ba sketch right truth is that
we've implemented and it's my side
project is really small project like
kind of website or small up I didn't
need high fidelity prototypes because i
was also implementing it but when i do
it for the clients and i go to the tools
such as experience design or retire i
will provide all of the links in the
video description below so the various
ways of learning you act by chance one
of them is following that with their
accounts and just on you're looking and
what so what's interesting for you there
are awesome there are some places and
people to follow our organizations one
of them is use norman group they publish
lee great report very interesting laws
greater sauce for those who are
interested is also look for black ski
and he's really really great going on
when it comes to giving the talks and
being a user advocate at east side you
will find
a lot of us some articles presentations
and you will also find a lot of great
talks that you gave and do too so you
can look at youtube another great source
of you acknowledge as for example of you
so i follow for example unix planet and
there are great articles i love
especially those written by this guy so
nick is really right when it comes to
examples and providing meaningful
explanations at us pin that is another
to start to you'll find a lot a lot of
free ebooks and this is also knowledge
that is like as if compensated in one
place first apart another very famous
place to for great articles i know that
that some developers who say I'm a
developer another designer so I don't
you know give a [ __ ] about this stuff
about design because it's not my thing
and nothing there will be people
responsible for you I and you know I
will not have to do it I'm not the kind
of person like that so I want to also
get to know someone at least basics from
the design and the usability and
accessibility stuff you don't have to be
experience designer you don't have to be
a graphic designer but you can make your
project stand out by knowing these few
simple rules start with a user and their
goals so start with the audience and
who will be really using this tonic they
care about visual hierarchy make sure
your texts your content it's really will
make sure that something that need to
needs to stand out stands out provide
just in time feedback try to make your
navigation intuitive and go to actions
at the right place in the right moment I
also focus on inconsistent so if i use
for example the action color that is
like mint green i will always use this
maintained for the action provide just
in time information so do not provide
long tutorials before the user viewing
starts using the product make users feel
secure and sure so explain what's needed
and do not require too much another
pretty crucial thing is to make it
responsive so start moving first it will
be easier for you to design the project
for your desktop version because on my
way we have less pain and as a result if
you have suddenly bar on the screen it
would be easier to fit to fit the
elements in that test test so test with
users test on various devices test in
various browsers remember about empty
States so the situation when a user
comes into your app for the first time
and you know there is no data provided
if you want to improve your projects and
decide learning to cope you also want to
get to know at least updates about user
experience design and recommend to start
with this book that is don't pay
anything and generate this offer because
it's really
when it comes to the basics of the
basics this week I was mostly working on
the client project and it was a design
project so I was practicing my skills
and experience design this week I have
also reached another milestone that is
500 brownie points in a free coke come
community and this way i have taught
myself the way to the next challenge is
bad i also prepare the bracket for
waking with subs and i created the
record for the new project the biggest
problem of this week was self-confidence
next week i will be implementing finally
planting my and about portfolio page and
i will be using flexbox sauce keep on
doing learn at least a bit about design
especially user experience design and
see you next week
[Music]